un truc sortir et ouais on peut
[Applaudissements]
râler si c'est déjà peur c'est pas
compliqué
on va trouver votre à venir à bout des
ongles et d'acier aussi d'un public
c'est fini ouais ok allant tout le monde
et croise les gens m'ont placé deux
pieds au sol bien sûr alors on essaie en
place les deux mains comme ça ici les
deux pompes de mains jointes en sont en
dépit les index en point les index en
direction du plafond on ouvre les doigts
enfin un espace de 1 cm entre les deux
doit fixer l'espace fixer les vides
entre les doigts imaginez maintenant que
je transfère ce les doigts avec une vis
et je prends la vis et je serre la vis
maintenant et regardez vos doigts qui se
rapproche ce code il sera plus de mise
en cours et doit se rapproche et
s'étonnant nom de plus en plus forts de
plus en plus coller de plus en plus
soudée qui doit resteront coincés à mon
signal au compte de 3-1 garder vos
doigts et avec le relais doit colle avec
le 2 de plus en plus collé comme des
aimants vaudois demeurent coincés avec
le 3 impossible de les bouger un pour
ceux de les séparer même si vous tentez
de la faire les dons ne bouge plus
coller et soudés ensemble n'est ce pas
un procès de les bouger les paupières se
ferment
les yeux fermés ouvrez votre esprit on
se rentrait vous sur ma voix
détendez vous relaxez vous commencez à
dormir avec le 1 le 2 et le 3 dormait
profondément vous vous sentez
merveilleusement bien dans un monde de
rêve et d'imaginaire et continuer de
dormir tout va bien concentrez-vous sur
ma voix vous continuer de dormir peu
importe ce qui se passait de temps je
vous dirai pas le contraire dans un
monde de rêve il d'imaginaire alors
maintenant on va le laisser dormir
l'émission est terminée c'est ça
les tudors il faut lui faire faire ce
monde de rêve et d'imaginaire
et maintenant syrie à mon signal
toujours dans un état d'hypnose allait
ouvrir les yeux regardez tous les
invités 1 2 3 on ouvrait les yeux il est
en train de laisser au repos
c'est quoi ok bah
ça va c'est incroyable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous l'avez tous fatigués car et après
dix ans passés ouais tu as fait le truc
non mais tu t'es pas bien elle est pas
bien du tout fatigué allez dire y aller
mais qu'est ce qui fait chuter ben là
c'est toi c'est toi qui me dit
elle va pas mener donc j'ai plus de
boulot
civelli regarder non
fermé les yeux et dormez dormez dormez
tout va bien dans mail et si vous allez
laisser vos portes et tout a bien
profité du moment et dormait
avant les jeux des véhicules non il est
chiant
les séries maintenant monsigna d'aller
vous éveillez complètement revenir à la
conscience avec un belle énergie un
autre et veille
[Musique]
au revoir oui
moi je dis au revoir moi je les sentais
pas la vôtre
qu'en est-il
[Applaudissements]
jamal
car tous ceux qui l'ont aidé à faire
c'est tout
ancien à 19h05 c'est pareil d'ici là
cette série twilight
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu